[Music]
Straight Ahead online crime dailies the
Final witness of the case is called in
Johnny Depp versus Amber Heard and this
is humiliating for any human being
to go through and you tried to get her
fired from the Aquaman after the
temporary restraining order didn't you
um well what is related to the story
about me again just yes yes or no Mr
depa Johnny Depp's testimony gets heated
Plus on xtmz employee pushes back on
cross-examination I'm not seeking any 15
minutes here until you may you're
welcome to speculate I could say the
same thing by taking Amber Heard as a
client for you and later I'll look ahead
to closing arguments I think they're
gonna have to cover a lot of ground but
they want to be thematic about it what
you can expect to hear from both sides
lawn crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
to Long crime daily I'm your host Brian
buckmeyer both sides rest in the Johnny
Depp versus Amber Heard defamation trial
this after her takes the stand once
again lawn crime Network correspondent
Jesse Weber is live at the Fairfax
County Courthouse with the highlights of
day 23. Jesse hey Brian yeah this was
the day we saw the conclusion of the
presentation of evidence and it started
off with Dr Richard Gilbert an
orthopedic surgeon who testified that
the injury to Johnny Depp's finger from
that Australia 2015 incident was
consistent with Depp's narrative that
heard through a vodka bottle Adam
shattering he discussed how this was a
fracture caused by force and by an
instrument that creates a laceration
that this was not from smashing or
pinching however on cross-examination he
did acknowledge that this injury could
have been caused by multiple things from
there it was a computer forensic
investig investigator called by heard to
support her argument that the photos of
her alleged bruised face were authentic
originals and not edited forensic
psychologist Dr Don Hughes testified
once again to defend her conclusions and
tests regard starting herds PTSD
diagnosis after facing criticism from Dr
Shannon Curry the day earlier but then
of course it was Amber Heard back on the
stand and she focused on the counter
claims the alleged defamatory Depp Adam
Waldman statements and the pain and
humiliation of Depp's actions
how did Mr Depp's statements and threats
to you how do those continue to manifest
themselves today in the harassment and
the humiliation the campaign against me
that's echoed every single day on social
media and now
in front of cameras in this room
every single day I have to relive the
trauma my hands Shake I wake up
screaming I I have to live with the
trauma and the Damage Done To Me
my friends have to live with a set of
unspoken rules about how to not touch me
not to surprise me
my intimate Partners have rules about
how they can deal with me how they can
touch me
I have rules for doctors and medical
professionals they see gynecologists I
see
I live my life with these sets of rules
that I have to follow my friends have to
follow for me not to have a panic attack
or a triggering event from what I've
survived I'm not sitting in this
courtroom snickering
I'm not sitting in this courtroom
laughing smiling and making snide jokes
this is horrible
this is painful
and this is humiliating for any human
being
to go through
and perhaps it's easy to forget that but
I'm a human being
and even though Johnny promised that I
deserve this and promised he'd do this I
don't deserve this
will I move on
but then things got very tense when she
was questioned by Camille Vasquez for
round two of cross-examination
you told this jury under oath that Mr
Depp was aggressive and trashed a
trailer in Hicksville you didn't expect
the manager of the Hicksville property
Morgan Knight to come forward and
testify that that wasn't true Did you
incorrect I've already been through
trials with this man I know how many
people will come out in support of him
when you told this jury under oath that
you had no idea that the paparazzi would
be at the courthouse on May 27 2016 you
didn't expect a TMZ employee to show up
to testify that TMZ had been alerted
that you would be at the courthouse and
knew exactly which side of your face to
take a picture of did you I know how
many people will come out and say
whatever for him that's his power that's
why I wrote the op-ed is I was speaking
to that phenomenon how many people will
come out in support of him and will fall
to his power he is a very powerful man
and people love currying favor with
powerful men
jail time for committing perjury
I didn't I didn't hear
in
Houston
Ms Vasquez if you do please just repeat
the question I didn't hear you Curry
favor and commit perjury in this
courtroom
I have seen people do this time and time
again that's why I wrote the op-ed
so clearly it was a strategic move on
heard's parts to be the last witness to
be testifying the question of course is
did it pay off well we've got closing
arguments and a potential verdict to
find out Brian
I mean that is the question Jesse so I'm
gonna I'm gonna ask it right off the top
of the bat heard gave a very impassioned
direct do you think that pushed the
needle of the case in her favor
well if you don't believe Amber Heard
From the Beginning then no if you're on
the fence then maybe I mean she really
humanized the pain she spoke to this
jury she related to this jury and by
saying and confirming that she was
psychologically mentally physically
abused by Johnny Depp that is what she
needs to show in order to overcome
Johnny Depp's defamation claim Johnny
Depp had his last time on the stand to
tell his story she did the same thing
yeah and and then now we've got to look
at the cross-examination because Camille
Vasquez she's been very effective in
cross-examinations throughout the entire
case but here we saw some sharp barbs
but did Hermes did herd's explanation
make sense though
this was an A plus cross-examination in
my opinion I mean she got Amber Heard to
lose her cool Amber Heard became
argumentative and certain of the
responses from Amber Heard you know
didn't quite make sense the idea that
anybody who disagreed with Amber heard's
account must be a Johnny Depp fan or a
Johnny Depp protector it might not be
believable and I know that she said that
she had no role in tipping off TMZ or
giving them the video but of course the
jury now knows that idea and they saw
that photo of her leaving with her
friend after the tro was filed smiling
no bruise on her face it could be
problematic for Amber Heard in the end
of the day yeah man in the end we kind
of got a little technical so my question
for you what can you gather from the
charge conference what facts will be
most important in the closing arguments
okay actual malice that definition is
going to be absolutely huge for the jury
for the defamation claim trying to show
that it was uh done the statements were
made with falsity or Reckless disregard
for the truth also whether or not Amber
heard's tweeting of the Washington Post
article constitutes republication
because she said she didn't write the
headline the sexual violence headline
should the Washington Post did that but
if the jury accepts that this was
republication they can attribute it to
Amber Heard and that could also be
problematic for Amber Heard to say that
she was actually sexually assaulted by
Johnny Depp yeah some very interesting
and important technical points to this
case that will have large repercussions
for closing arguments Jesse stick with
us for just a second we back in a moment
still ahead on bond crime daily a closer
look at Johnny Depp's rebuttal case our
analysts break down the major points of
depth cross-examination that's ahead on
Long crime B
foreign
[Music]
welcome back as part of Johnny Depp's
rebuttal case this week the actor took
the stand for a second time on
cross-examination herds attorneys asked
Depp about herd's role in Aquaman
you were pretty angry after misheard got
her temporary restraining order weren't
you
I was more than anything I Was Heard
and you testified earlier this morning
you claim that you
you somehow were responsible for her
getting a role uh with Warner Brothers
correct
that's what you testify to this morning
you also you also tried to get her fired
from Aquaman didn't you
um after the temporary restraining order
which question would you like me to
handle first one question sir you tried
to get her fired from the Aquaman after
the temporary restraining order didn't
you
um well what is related to the story
about me again you just yes yes or no Mr
Depp I I don't know yes I I can't please
you with a yes or a no every single time
it's a yes or no question you tried to
get Mr fired didn't you answers no
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney Jack Rice co-host Terry Austin
and Lawn crimes Jesse Weber Jack how did
Deb's cross go compare it to the first
time he was cross-examined
it's always about risk versus reward his
first time on the stand was absolutely
brilliant he missed nothing he came
across as self-deprecating funny really
honest pulling the curtain back that was
amazing the problem in this particular
case is what I found that he was a
little more defensive and I think he
opened himself up a little bit and I
really questioned just the benefit that
he brought the second time around yeah
it's interesting that's the risk you you
you play when you have a witness or a
client testify more than once Terry two
different versions of why that made that
call to Warner Brothers which one Rings
true to you
well I think you know either one could
be true and that's going to be up for
the jury to decide but heard claims that
depth tried to get her fire after the
tro what he says is that he initially
got her the job they were concerned
about her acting ability and he said
listen don't worry and he claims that he
called them and he wasn't trying to get
them fired he just wanted to clarify
what was going on he was in one
franchise he was in another franchise
and he wanted to make sure that Warner
Brothers understood what was going on
out in the Press because they were
hearing these rumors so it just depends
on what the jury thinks yeah an ex
trying to mess up another's career makes
sense but also rescinding your
um kind of Praise of someone after you
realize something about them also makes
sense but Jesse the question is is this
argument about what Depp said to Warner
Brothers another credibility argument or
does it go directly to the heart of the
Washington Post op-ed
I believe this goes to the heart of the
idea that he was trying or the
allegation was that he was trying to
ruin her whole life to destroy her whole
career it goes to the counter claim
argument that he and Adam Waldman were
orchestrating this campaign to tarnish a
reputation to tarnish her credibility
and I think that's what it's really
centered on on top of the fact he's all
they're also trying to make the point
that he was vindictive and mean and if
this is what he was engaging with
towards her after the relationship then
what was he doing during the course of
their relationship and it maybe supports
the overall abuse allegations well both
sides have two hours in closing
arguments I'm sure we're going to hear
this and so much more Jesse as always
thank you for the Stellar reporting
looking forward to hearing from you soon
thanks Brian coming up on Law and crime
daily a last minute witness makes an
internet Splash Why Elaine benhoff
called the former TMZ employee
argumentative during testimony
[Music]
welcome back a former TMZ employee
becomes a last-minute witness for a
depths team testifying about her's
restraining order photos taken after TMZ
received a tip on cross-examination
things got heated with herd's attorney
misheard was filing a restraining order
at a courthouse in downtown Los Angeles
so um I dispatched camera people to that
location
under what circumstances would you
normally send Paparazzi to a courthouse
uh only if we had been informed prior
it's not by any means a celebrity hot
spot we would only ever send people
there if we had been tipped off that
something was occurring and there was
somebody present there
and what footage was TMZ trying to
capture at the LA Courthouse on May 27
2016. we were trying to capture uh amber
leaving the courthouse and an alleged
bruise on the right side of her face
what was your team of Paparazzi supposed
to do while they were at the Los Angeles
courthouse on May 27 2016. their
objective was to capture her leaving the
courthouse and then she was going to
sort of stop and turn towards the camera
to display the bruise on the right side
of her face the electric spruce
did your team of videographers get the
shot of Amber Heard we did we did so
this gets you your 15 minutes of fame
objection your honor argumentative I I
can ask that a question oh ruled
um so I stand to gain nothing from this
I'm actually putting myself kind of in a
target of TMZ a very litigious uh
organization and I'm not seeking any 15
minutes here though you may you're
welcome to speculate I could say the
same thing by taking Amber Heard as a
client for you
a little argumentative don't you think
oh hardly I find that to be purely
logical a little argumentative I mean a
great I mean it's a great point but
Terry do you think it was effective for
adapt to call the TMZ representative
oh my gosh Brian yes yes yes I think
Morgan Tremaine was excellent he was
last minute so frankly they didn't have
to give him notice because it was a
rebuttal witness and so it surprised I
think the other team and he testified
about this tip that he got about the tro
and coming to the courthouse and taking
photos of her bruise and no one else
would have been able to give that
information but either Amber Heard or
someone on her team he also got a tip
about her deposition and they were able
to get her arriving at the deposition
but the biggest thing was that video of
you know depth slamming those cabinets
that had to come from heard she copied
it and she admitted that she took it and
they were able to download it in 15
minutes and you can only do that it it
comes from the source and she edited it
he was brilliant brilliant brilliant and
yes he was argumentative but not too
argumentative yeah now now Jack his
response turned into a bit of a viral
moment so to speak and we're all
laughing about it but the question is
how's this going to play out in front of
the jury what do you think
I don't think the jury likes heard's
lawyer very much and I think good for
the goose the problem is is you roll
that out there you better be prepared
for what comes back at you and I think
that's how the jury saw this because to
some degree I think they're looking at
all the lawyers like that I mean we're
not exactly uh the highest on the list
of people they trust anyway isn't that
true
I don't know I'm a public defender
everyone trusts me Jack no one ever
think okay again that public defenders
lie that's what my wife tells me we're
very trustworthy people but I would
never lie to you never oh my God but I
agree with you it's gonna be it's gonna
be interesting to see how it plays it's
all about credibility and sometimes
likability so we'll see where the jury
is swayed on this and so many other
issues when we come back a look ahead at
closing arguments who presents for each
side and what you can expect in the
final moments of the trial
foreign
[Music]
welcome back after six weeks of
testimony we're inching closer to the
highly anticipated closing arguments in
the Johnny Depp versus Amber Heard trial
long crime Network Sierra Gillespie
explains what we could expect to see in
closings
this is what you've been dreaming of
your whole life you do a closing
argument in a huge jury trial like this
and this one's going to be on national
TV all eyes are focused I mean if you
wanted to be a lawyer this is what you
wanted six weeks of testimony will
culminate in only four hours of closing
arguments two hours per side Wendy sum
it up they have to make sure they focus
on the theme of their case ever since
they they stated it in the opening
statement and then also they have to
make sure that they hit all the elements
of the defamation claim they have to
pull all of the pictures the recordings
we've which we've heard so much
the testimony I didn't know if the
bottle
that he had inside me was broken
made contact
and shattered put that in a cohesive
story that the jury can bring with them
during deliberation closings are
expected to be presented for depth side
by Camille Vasquez and Benjamin Chu
Camille Vasquez definitely is sort of
the Breakthrough star of the show here I
bet she's the one who's going to address
the question of whether Amber Heard was
actually abused by Johnny Depp Ben shoe
probably has the overall task of kind of
tying the case together maybe he'll do
the damages part of the case for Johnny
Depp heard's closing argument is
expected to be presented by Elaine
bretahof and Jay Benjamin rottenborn Ben
rottenborn will probably take on Johnny
Depp try to assert that he was an abuser
and I think Elaine bretahof will
probably address the other issues the
experts the damages and Amber heard's
counterclaim closings are set to be
presented on Friday reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie all
right jack what are we expecting will be
heard strongest arguments or what will
they likely argue the most to beat Deb's
claim and win their counter claim
I would make broad-based themes in a
case like this the brutality that she
saw the the pain the anguish the
destruction of Amber Heard if you look
back at the Washington Post op-ed what
she wrote was that a powerful man will
come in and take the abused and Destroy
them at every single level and if you
look at what's happened to Amber Heard
at every single level will she ever work
again will anybody ever believe her at
any level about anything does it matter
what she does now would it make any
difference because a powerful man has
done exactly what she said me too is
real and the problem is is Johnny Depp
did exactly what it is that she claimed
he would do this is proof one is the
other she is bookended by both
all right I think Brendan Hoff and uh
Rottenberg are probably taking notes
right now listening to Jack Ryan says to
what that closing argument will be Terry
same question how do you win the claim
beat the counterclaim but for Johnny
Depp's side
well I think what Johnny Depp has to do
and I think he's done it for the most
part he has to prove that that
Washington Post article was about him
and not many people noticed but today
heard actually slipped up and said she
wrote that article to confront what did
Jack say Depp's power and influence so
there's no question that article was
about Johnny Depp he also has to show
that her comments were false and it was
made with malice because of course he's
a public figure and we know that her
injuries have been exaggerated they
haven't been documented and so if you
conclude and a jury might conclude that
all of this violence did not occur
therefore those comments were false and
she made those comments maliciously I
think it will be a little bit harder
Brian for Depp to prove those counter
claims because we know the judge has
already ruled that Waldman his attorney
those comments are his because Waldman
is his agent if that's the case those
were damaging and we have to see whether
or not the jury connects those comments
to damages so we'll see what happens at
that time there's a lot to consider here
as we Edge closer and closer to closing
arguments thank you both and of course
thank you for joining us here along
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss Justice in America
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]